[Música]
sobre su país mientras sus seguidores
encomendaban a Dios durante el recuento
de votos Yair bolsonaro obtuvo el
domingo pese a su segundo puesto en la
primera vuelta una importante Victoria
Por una parte el presidente brasileño
obtuvo unos resultados mejores de los
que pronosticaba las encuestas en su
carrera a la reelección pero su Victoria
legislativa fue otro de sus grandes
alivios en su cita con las urnas la
nación Sudamericana renovaba los 513
asientos de su cámara de diputados y un
tercio de los 81 escaños del senado el
partido liberal la formación del
ultraderechista logró hacerse con 99
asientos frente a los 80 escaños que
obtuvo la federación de partidos de
izquierda de lulada Silva en el senado
un paisaje semejante con los liberales
de ultraderecha marcando la Pauta con la
mayoría además bolsonaro logró que
figuras polémicas de su entorno lograran
escaños como el exministro de salud
Eduardo pasuelo criticado por su gestión
de la pandemia el ex titular de medio
Ricardo sales famoso por su
desmantelamiento de los órganos de
control ambiental o Sergio Moro el juez
que encarceló a Lula da Silva las
expectativas del presidente ya eran
altas al inicio de la jornada
expectativa de Victoria hoy teniendo en
cuenta los resultados en un momento
difícil para el país en general y en
estos 45 días de campaña ganamos en
prácticamente todos los estados de
Brasil y los recibimos muy bien pese a
todo las encuestas de cara al balotaje
siguen dando una mayoría al candidato
del partido de los trabajadores que se
comprometió a reforzar su campaña las
próximas semanas
es lo siguiente la lucha continúa hasta
la victoria final Ese es nuestro lema si
lo la gana Eso sí deberá enfrentarse a
un poderoso legislativo opositor que no
se lo pondrá nada fácil un congreso
mayoritariamente ultraconservador blanco
y masculino